what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch from
new rock stars She-Hulk episode 5 Easter
eggs and breakdown from Jessica Clemens
we
are Jessica Clemons We Stand Jessica
Clement we are all Jessica Clements I am
Jessica Clement I am Jessica oh I am
Jessica Clemens The Authority doesn't
know who to strike down we can't strike
along
anyways don't hurt you I am Jessica
Clemens my friend how are you I am
Jessica Clement all right guys leave a
like go ahead subscribe click the
notification Bell and uh yeah we didn't
do last week's I'm just realizing d23
was happening there's a lot coming out
let's get into it
[Music]
welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemons here to break down
episode five of She-Hulk for you the
episode we got a better look at Titania
and all her vapid influence her glory
more insight into the world is fine the
superhero looks and some fun non-stop
Easter eggs we open to a song called
higher written by Mark Campbell we get
the famous pass by effect this time on a
pink screen that says She-Hulk by
Titania Titania has a new luxury
skincare Beauty and wellness product
line named She-Hulk look at the strong
female driven campaign montages of
Titania wearing this 600 dress we know
she's fashionable our girl is currently
at New York Fashion Week I love the pr
She-Hulk and Jamila Jamil are doing this
is also just giving it that's pretty fun
literally all beauty commercials ever
made as Jen drives her Prius through
West Hollywood I just want to say it's
really easy to overlook something like
that but that is a wonderful emulation
of what those commercials are actually
like I was just sticking that I was like
that must have taken so much work to
capture the exact like aesthetic and
everything about that and also the
street that they cut to where uh
Jennifer Walters is driving down when
she sees the billboard I hate driving
down Road it's always so busy and it's
never this smooth the way how the show
is making it look nope that is not
reality nope not at this time of day as
Jen drives her Prius through West
Hollywood
sign we see the giant billboard for
Titania's pop up at the Grove which is a
giant Shopping Center in Los Angeles
it's super packed celebs have been
spotted there I guess from time to time
I guess that's the height I don't really
like it the promo code thank you
Titania is a farmer's market is nice
very much me Jen is listening to Pro Se
law 360s podcast which is a real weekly
podcast on law 360. law 360 is the
overarching umbrella that covers legal
news giving quick coverage on issues
that affect attorneys Business Leaders
and Regulators Titania fans are also
confirmed called titaniacs by Titania on
the radio Chad comes barreling through
Jen's apartment Jen lock your damn door
this is happening so much I'm sure
towards the end of the season we'll get
someone clearly not good strolling I do
find that funny considering how this
show is often addressing the dangers of
what it's like to be a woman and how she
never locks her door no Los Angeles
that's the one sitcom Trope that usurps
her perspective as a character after Jen
mansplains trademarking law to Jen but
in reality who's really the smart one
now She-Hulk you can even trademark it
but Chad knows he always knows we get
our title screen this time it's pink my
favorite color and with a little
feminine glow lens flare that was once
the color green but now it's pink by
Titania is in cursive at the bottom
instead of its normal attorney at law
the voiceover says by titanium thank you
yeah down in exactly like Kim Kardashian
just like me I'm sure it's the added
influencer Valley Girl Vibe overall it's
looking like a Titania episode so let's
just get really into it we're at Titania
She-Hulk pop-up at the sunset Arts
District I don't think there's a sunsets
Arts District but there's an actual Arts
District in downtown L.A also how do I
get that Titania cardboard cut out
please someone at Marvel at me and give
it to me when Jen noticed the snake
venom lips she says snake venom lip
flower Venom she's literally selling
snake oil which is a saying in reference
to all those Miracle elixirs or those
fraudulent marketing schemes people make
this place is Wild on the wall we see
TVs featuring Titania dressed in her
Sunburst Crown in space like a beautiful
space goddess and I hate to be that
person but I agree with Nikki Jen these
are all different products Beauty serum
for your face for aging Beauty oil is
usually soften the skin keep the
moisture in and Beauty tonic is like
high in vitamin C usually good for
Plumping I just use a ton of different
products I want your skin looks so good
either way we get a look at Nikki's desk
which is very Nicki Ramos her plaque few
office supplies the Titania lip gloss
sample she got earlier along with this
cute mini stack of donut keychains and
dumpster fire toy created
that soft it also comes with a
nightlight one I've gifted these before
so I'm really happy to see this like
little color oh that's neat yeah episode
needing Nikki to stand in line with him
for those damn fine Iron Man 3s we saw
in earlier episodes time and time again
like every sneaker head nose you need
one to rock and one stock baby I do
appreciate that because that isn't an
Easter egg that a lot of people caught
in a previous episode that's actually
carrying over into an actual plot Point
yeah Following episode I think that's it
I don't know there's something kind of
neat about that because we're just going
to throw away Easter egg like a lot of
these well yeah it's like it makes the
world feel a bit more tangible in a way
you wouldn't ever expect because it's
such a small detail but in a way it's
ground level that's for us it's World
building his guy is known as Alonso the
drip broker now I've been told the term
drip broker exists but I refuse to use
it ever again after today it's just too
silly for me either way of passion
progress someone that acts as an
intermediary between a fashion brand and
a manufacturer so in this case the brand
being She-Hulk the manufacturer being
Luke Jacobson Alonso could easily be
some random dude but just how fun would
it be if it was Zemo the man loves
fashion and had an infomercial on Marvel
Studios assembled about fashion called
sukovia or it could be 100 soft like
they said on Twitter that's why zemo's
not in the Thunderbolts he's starting a
fashion line and there's going to be a
whole show about that Cafe bobay I might
pronounce that wrong and I'm so sorry
the front for the superhero clothing
business we've got another QR code that
takes you to the She-Hulk Marvel comic
page the She-Hulk issue number 10. for
free and in a messed up way we learn
Nikki can speak Chinese or at least say
we're not cops in it before we say that
this is Jubilee from X-Men reference
it's also the name for restaurant items
and some famous cleaning supplies
intentional this is made by her husband
at 100 soft y'all check them out they're
all super cute they have a collection of
Marvel currently definitely recognize
the aesthetic politely off Avenger
undies and cups that say thur and Hulk
Hulk as Borat beach towel Captain
America I love it I want one from the
60s Avengers issue number four but note
it's not quite the one we're used to the
shirts that say Avengers and Avengers we
see the Avengers mug in the courtroom
illustrations too let's notice what's
off shall we Thor's shovel instead of a
hammer which is hilarious because they
off-road Thor's hammer not only does
Hulk have a mustache but the protruding
nipples are a nice touch Iron Man's
colors are backwards also the error on
the chest Hawkeyes has like a hawk foot
bow
Furniture we've got this very cute
Captain America but he has an eagle on
his hat chest and shield looks like a
football player that was the wings on
the side of his helmet and black widow
has a red scorpion on her chest also not
to mention the arrow in Avengers is
pointing the opposite direction it
normally does an Avengers this is a
second hand way to get around copyright
I love it also the team we never knew we
needed is pug and Nikki I love them so
much though I've talked a lot of crap
about Mallory I respect her
professionalism where she's taking
Titania and she hopes case as a
professional courtesy I love this line
why didn't you trademark your own suit
in him and I mentioned it in episode two
breakdown that Stan Lee had to trademark
She-Hulk quick they created She-Hulk
from the success of the Incredible Hulk
the TV series and with the bionic woman
being so popular it seemed like a good
idea Marvel was afraid that CBS would
introduce a female version of Hulk so
they decided to publish their own
version so if any show made something
similar Marvel would own the right that
sounds like a more interesting courtroom
drama scenario than what she depicted
that would be great for season two
especially know you get even further
into the fourth wall in the metaness
when they actually get to boys territory
where they start making TV adaptations
of the Marvel characters I bet they
could do that I know that you know there
are people who often disagree with us
about the way the courtroom scenes are
handled that it's just supposed to be
funny that editing our last episode
reaction that was one of the top
comments was people going back and forth
about whether the courtroom drama scenes
are good enough for or not good enough I
don't know I hear like a description
like that I'm like that sounds like a
fascinating thing to explore of having
to trademark your own name in the fight
for that I feel like this show could
have done a better job at making
something still funny but also
compelling simultaneously kind of like
Spider-Woman it's just easier to
trademark but it got me thinking yeah
what about Hulk Iron Man Spider-Man
Hawkeye do they have to trademark their
names no of course not because they
don't have Petty people in their lives
like Titania but I'm also sure Iron Man
probably did also fun fact that the word
superhero was trademarked by Marvel and
DC Comics in the 60s allegedly Marvel oh
my God leave you alone if you use it
casually and as long as it stays off the
cover you can use it in comics what I'm
just trying to say what whoa what please
don't come at me for spreading this
knowledge our judge to an episode is
that ridiculous Jesus judge early played
by Mary Kraft Titania's lawyer is Robert
Wallace played by Darren tunder also I
hate that if you're going to steal
someone's name Titania don't make your
product pink and green that makes no
sense we see one clip where Jen refuses
the name She-Hulk and our second clip is
from Bob De Castro's interview in
episode 3 of She-Hulk we're now at Luke
Jacobson's and if you're like mt you
probably already peep the confused
Eugene padelio Delio that's how Mt says
a padillo Eugene is completely confused
walking out so it must be his first time
there oh my God
he could potentially be picking up the
suit for his father the OG leak frog in
the comics or for someone else Eugene
could steal the costume that was
supposed to go somewhere else the
theories are endless here but we got a
good Glimpse at mt's boy oh that is wild
we even slowed that scene down before
doing the review and uh we did not
notice that at all I guess you got to
know who that actor is yeah who should
have noticed it as koi yeah koi doesn't
matter if we didn't notice it's quite
noticing you're not here right now why
do you come here koi if you don't notice
them yes things shame we're also
introduced to Luke Jacobson played by
the amazing Griffin Matthews Luke
Jacobson is a famous designer from
Marvel Comics he was an award-winning
designer in fashion Mogul and he worked
alongside Dakota North appearing in
Dakota North comics in the 80s and the
first thing he does is Scream but not
out of fear of She-Hulk but at her
ghastly outfit also just want to note
we've seen Sun designers in the comics
like Leo zielinski who tailored costumes
for the X-Men Avengers doom and a ton of
other folks then we've got folks like
Spider-Man who made his own original
then got an updated suit from Tony Stark
Thor's who was basically as guardian
armor Melvin Potter and Daredevil but
this Loop is the real deal and Edna Mode
of the MCU and I ain't seeing anything
we can see clothes they're currently
working on including this nice striped
sort of 16th century armored dress but
it's also given slightly an Olympian
fighter Vibe this looks similar to
something someone like Athena or Sif
would probably wear just like a fighter
or Warrior type the black feather one
could be for someone with either
exaggerated burr-like features like beak
or just spooky when we turn around we
see the black head mask piece with black
horns could be for someone it's a wild
Theory like Lilith or magic I'd be very
surprised if these gods and
demons
if there's one thing no Heaven or Hell
realm can provide it is the drift I do
everything street level God level
doesn't matter whatever you need Quantum
clothes I got it I'm a go-to guy for
everyone and everything villains and
heroes all around next to it we see a
gold and green shiny fabric which sort
of reminds me of Jean Gray and Loki's a
straw dress which is insane and an
armored nipples like our favorite Batman
and before you guys come at me that was
a joke nipple Batman is not my favorite
Batman we see Mallory from Jen's last
date the one that was calling her
miracle workers John bass mentioned at
d23 Todd is a billionaire playboy
philanthropist douchebag who wants more
than anything to feel like Tony Stark he
is used to getting whatever he wants but
he's a total creep who starts popping up
everywhere this reminds me of Kristoff
in the 2014 She-Hulk run who had a ton
of money was very much a bachelor
Playboy but wanted asylum in the U was
from latvaria he was Dr Doom's son and
it's very fun run maybe Todd won't be
Kristoff but give the same energy of
demanding she hoped to be there for him
or just getting whatever he wants like a
crybaby like me I think he's also
drinking the really expensive Saratoga
Water which is like 84 for like three I
wish I lived that life I'm not gonna lie
I don't really care to see that much
more of that guy
why you don't you're not Charmed that
was a lot of emphasis on this one
character and it sounds like that actor
did a lot of homework to become this guy
I'm okay if we never see him again I
like that actor so I'm rooting for him
but also I I can't exactly disagree I'm
not like give me more of this guy man I
don't hate him but I'm like there's no
need to do we really need to build this
guy up pop it up everywhere come on we
don't need to do all that when we take a
look at Jen's dating profile or her
About Me section says mean green and
straight poured into these jeans which
is the great title of this episode also
Jen was looking to a sturdy back and
read reinforced king-sized bed Jen oh my
God I love that look I know you met on
the site that is oh this is horrible
also each of their gestures already
reflect the type of people and energy
they give off that is a good thing so
we're reintroducing the great shot in
the last episode Derek the strong one
Noah the director Todd who we've seen
too much of I just don't like him and
Arthur the one she took home now what
Arthur says here about not wanting to
date Jen but wanting to date She-Hulk
can easily be connected to the comics
but also just to be in a human in the
comics Jen was so attached to the
spectacle that was She-Hulk she never
wanted to be Jen Walters because she
wasn't fun or outgoing enough as Jen
this scene hurt me so much because Jen
is Jen She-Hulk is Jen and I don't want
her getting any warped idea that no one
likes Jen which is something we'll
probably dive into more in the next
coming episodes it's basically like them
just trying to coexist together as Jen
and She-Hulk like banners but obviously
like completely different Titania says
this is my favorite part of this episode
It's new footage it indeed is not over
She-Hulk will punch her in the face soon
we still haven't got the answer as to
why this whole beef event started but we
can bang on seeing titanium more I don't
think she'll be the big bad of the
series but a speed bump along the way oh
that's offensive to be referred to as a
speed bump in the comics like I said
definitely or Jen and Mallory don't get
along but I like the idea of even a
weird messy way she can become friends
with Jen who needs girls versus girls
beefing they're two class A lawyers
let's not put them against each other uh
C'est La Vie we're back at the legalese
bar and on the TV at the same anchor
from the second episode for kzyo Jen
breaks the fourth wall talking this time
for the first time this episode when she
reminds us remembering she needs to
check out her new clothes She-Hulk
arrives at Luke's to pick up her clothes
we can probably expect to see few fits
from the trailers like this dress that
makes her ass look amazing her She-Hulk
suit and the new fitted suit there's
probably a bunch of options now and also
hold up Tinsley slow down our boy is
making a new outfit for Daredevil it's
the gold helmet we've seen in the
trailers it will never be forgotten and
it's for pickup this is why Charlie is
in La picking up his new threads okay
now I don't want to spoil anything but
if you do want d23 sport Oilers boss
gives one away on inside Marvel they got
an exclusive little teaser if she helped
with Daredevil there I know some of you
are watching this from afar I don't want
to make you sprint from your kitchen to
mute me while I give you spoilers so
just click on over there and you'll get
more insight into the shenanigans that
ensue I actually don't know anything
about what there was reveal a d23 of
that footage I'm waiting for the show to
tell me absolutely but you just reminded
me of very important details that I for
some reason did not think about at all
Daredevil in Los Angeles
she said it and immediately it clicked
it I was like oh that's right
level of Hell's Kitchen I'm so used I
didn't even think like he's he went
there only to get his costume made
that's the only he's gonna be there for
another reason he's got to be there for
another reason nobody couldn't get the
job done yes you let me down for the
last time I needed the perfect fashion
designer I have to go as far away from
you as possible because like Jacobson is
the only way his gear is is so his suit
is is it's just for aesthetic purposes
for a blind guy
I'm looking for a very specific look it
is
yeah he's become a little bit more
materialistic that's right he's really
enjoying that lawyer's salary we closed
the episode to Tove strike I know I
pronounced that wrong with the song is
so good it's called say my name on the
nose we get some new courtroom
illustrations Chad hustling selling
She-Hulk merch now signed by our
She-Hulk Holloway drinking the booty
booster he saw in Santa Monica
now this is pretty fun Mickey and pug
are checking out what I assume is the
Iron Man threes we see so many shoes on
this wall and I'm gonna try clicking on
all of them and we'll try to figure it
out Captain America we got Deadpool we
got black panther we got Cyclops Vision
I think this is old school like comic
Vision not our newer Vision the thing
Wolverine I say this is Cape Bishop you
can say Hawkeye I think it's fine frog
man Bishop uh from the X-Men that's so
cool green gobbles AKA The Green Goblin
Captain Marvel Spider-Man Moon Knight so
people are saying here this could be
Gambit because of the Spade but the
colors match Jack of Hearts too well and
he has like yeah
oh yes Falcon Nova Ghost Rider Doctor
Strange the Juggernaut Juggernaut
dang we couldn't figure out who that was
yeah Juggernaut is that's actually the
perfect catch yeah I think the closest
anyone got at the time was what old
school uh Hank Pim Ant-Man yeah but yeah
Juggernaut dang I wouldn't even thought
damn you're right that is totally
Juggernaut oh that's cool dude coming
he's coming he's going to bust through
the wall like titanium then she's gonna
have to defend him good call on also
that not being Gambit that was a great
call yeah I also think it's fun to have
different opinions so if you disagree
that's fine that's the cool part about
being different people we can have
differences
like teaser so it was a little bit short
and so it was my little breakdown follow
me on Instagram and Twitter at Lulu
underscore Clemons ball a new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching and remember once we're
rocking and ones for stalking baby
that's right
fantastic work again
Jessica Clemens excellent number one
yeah look out Voss no longer are you the
king I was saying that we're number two
oh we're at least number two number two
like Clemens number three I was keeping
the bit going there's no need to put
down Eric Voss for no prize sorry that
was not very Jessica Clemens of me
Jessica Clemens would not do that I have
you are not a real Justice I will do it
take him to the extermination
I just want to be Jessica Clements
all right guys well if you're mad at
John for talking [ __ ] on Eric Voss for
some reason we got no reason for that we
got beef uh leave your thoughts Down
Below on that and uh hey we will see you
all soon
bye
[Music]